how do you represent clients that you
know are guilty I believe in the way our
justice system works people have a right
to representation and I do the best I
can for them any lawyer who says to you
that they don't represent people that
make them morally uncomfortable is
either lying or has a very inert
practice like yeah I represent horrible
people sometimes are there times where I
feel icky about that absolutely there's
a chapter in my book about a case I
should not have won I represented a
horrible person who beat a woman un
mercifully and we won because I knew the
Rules of Evidence better than the other
lawyer and he had more money so he could
afford me and she got a court assigned
lawyer had hardly any idea what they
were doing and I ate their lunch for
them and as we walked out he patted me
on the shoulder and he said one good
lawyer is better than 20 stickup men and
I remember I felt dirty the reality is
capitalism baby you get as much justice
as you can afford